よろしくお願いします
で 今日の話のテーマ 無明ということと十二因縁ということだと言われまして
そのテーマでいくらか話そうと思っています
で そのテーマのによって喋ると
皆様に直接役に立つかどうか分かりませんだけど
とにかく我々の人生に役に立つようにあの努力はします
役に立つような話になるように
で なぜかというと まあ釈尊の教えにおいては
あの とても難しい 人間には理解できないというか
人間の能力は まあ因縁を理解できるところまではまあならないということ
で で 難しいとおっしゃっているし
そこはわかったならば
その場で人はすべての煩悩をなくして
心は解脱する自由を得るんです
いわゆる生命としてのすべての問題はそこで解決するんです
そういうことで 我々のこの釈尊の教えを教えている人々にとっては
大変とてつもない難しい話なんですね
因縁と無明という話は
で 他の仏教においては
まあそれはあまりも簡単単純で見ているみたいし
で ですから まあ他のいろいろ仏教では
まあこれはまあ無明やら行やらなんとか
それだけでしょうというふうな感じで
そんな話ではなくて まあ仏教は空の話ですよと
偉そうにまあ大変威張っておっしゃっていらっしゃいますし
ですから このそちらの因十二因縁の話とこちらの十二因縁の話は
まあぴったし合わないかもしれません
で この話は私は東大仏教会でも回分けてずっと因縁のことを話したんですね
その時もまあちゃんと釈尊がおっしゃった因縁ってどういうものかと
まあちゃんと教えたらどうですか？と言われて
はい わかりましたと もう教えたんだけど
結果としてはまるっきり認めてくれなかったんですね
内容は ということは 自分の頭にある話は十二因縁であり
それはもうとんで まあものすごい軽い
まあほんのちょっと漫画みたいな話だと思っていて
私が言ったことはわからなかったんだから
まあただ私の話を認められなかっただけ
で また同じ話を覚えて覚えてますけど
あの 渋谷の一一 一 一進寺ですか
一人寺でしたっけ あの会の名前は
そちらでも何回か分けて話しましたし
そこでは別に理解してもらおうともらわないかというところではなくて
ただ内容を紹介することだけで
で それでも難しかったと思います
テーラワーダ協会の場合でも
まあ回か回 同じテーマを喋った覚えはあります
で だから難しいというならば難しいし
まあ一番基本的なことしか喋れませんし
で 深みに入ろうと思ったら
まあそういう時間を得られないだろうと思いますよ
私にも で いつでも私は言いますけど
私は昔 遠い昔の話なんですけど
この教師 大学で教師をやっていた時は
この仏教哲学の場合は
まあなんて言いますか
この清浄道論のこの十年のテキスト
それを授業としてやらなくちゃいけないことになりまして
そのテキストを読むところから
1 年間の授業でイントロダクションで終わったんです
因縁 因縁ってどういうことかと
で その場合はこういうふうな説法の形ではなくて
授業だからきちんとデータやら資料やらずっと出しっぱなしで
もういろんな人の教えやら考え方やらね
対照しながら比べながら喋るところだから
それでもイントロダクションで一年終わってしまったんですね
で 学生たちに言ったのは
まあ本当はテキストは 1
2 ページも読めなかったんだけど
あなた方がこれぐらい理解しておけば
もうそれでももう相当なものですよと
である友達が その私はそのイントロダクションに作った内容をもらって
自分の博士論文を作ったんです
ですから まあ学問的にはそれぐらいの要領というか内容なんですね
で それ内容に入ってないんです
その時のただイントロダクションっていうのは紹介だけ
で 私たちの立場はまた違うんですね
こちらで皆様いらっしゃっているのは
なんか偉そうな もう頭難しい何か話を聞こうとかね
そういうことというよりは
私たちの人生に何か役に立ちますかということなんですね
ですから まあそこは決して小さな目的とは言えないんです
本当にその方が一番大事なんです
で 役に立つか立たないかと
役に立たなかったら どんな偉大なる教えであろうか
もう何の意味もないんですね
ですから このお釈迦様もそこら辺はやっぱり大事に考えたんですね
ただ単に自分が頭がいいんだ
すごいんだとみんなに褒めてもらうために
難しいことをペラペラ喋ったっても
誰にも役に立たないとわからないならば
何の意味もないんですね
ですから 難しいことを知ろうというのは
まあ知られる能力があるならば別に構いませんだけど
まあ理解もできないのに
苦労して苦労して知ったんだからといって
まあ何も意味がない そうではなくて
それより私たちの生き方に役に立つ
我々の生き方 正しい方向へ導くことできる
そういう実践的な側面は一番大事なんですね
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃるのは
全部経典を勉強するよりは
ほんのわずかな一行 二行
三行 四行でもよく理解して実行に移るならば
その人こそ素晴らしいんだと
で 法華経の第一章の最後の偈文に出てくるんだけど
もう難しく難しく すべての経典を勉強する人が
ただ人の牧場ですか 人の牧場で一日の給料に仕事をする人と同じですよと
一生懸命牛の面倒を見て餌をあげて
必死になって その人は面倒は見るんだけど
インド風に言えば牛っていうのは財産だからね
その財産から得る得は一つもその人のものではありません
それは全部牛の持ち主のものなんですね
彼が仕事をしたんだから
1 日終わったら給料だけもらって帰ると
牛乳でも乳製品でも牛たちでも何でも彼のものじゃないんですね
ですから 難しく勉強する
のは 大体それぐらいのものだと
で わずかなお経でも聞いて理解して
自分を励んで心を清らかにするならば
その人が本当のこの相続人だと
この仏教の財産の それはまあ
牛を自分で牧場を持っている人と同じなんですね
牧場を持っている人の子供たちにも
それの 財産の権利があって
幸福を得られるんですね
ですから この仏教の本当の相続人になるためには
難しいことを勉強するよりは
自分に役に立つような方向へ変えて勉強なさった方がいいだろうとは思います
前提としてそれを置いておいて
で 無明のお話に入ります
で その清浄浄浄道論ですか
ビスディマッガという
このテーラワーダ仏教の一番大事な基本になるテキストがあります
これ かなり大きいテキストなんです
で その書いたお坊さんの名前はブッダゴースと言うんですけど
それももしかすると当てなかもしれませんだけど
テーラワーダ世界ではもうものすごいありがたいお坊さんなんですね
でお経はあったんだけど
それはずっと今まで すべての人々に理解できるように
注釈書を全部整理して
パーリ語で書いたのはほとんどではなくて
いくらか残りましたけど
そのお坊さんなんです
そのお坊さんが書いた論文なんですね
浄道論というのは  そちらではこの仏教の基本的な考え方を全部まとめて
ものすごい複雑に説明しているんですね
そのテキストの一部があの十二因縁の説明なんです
で すごい能力あったお坊さんなんですよ
もう恐ろしいほど知識があったんです
そういう人がこの十二因縁の話になったところで
私は大きな海に落ちて溺れて溺れているような状態ですよと
どうにもならない状態になりましたと
この十二因縁を説明しようとする
する私がそんな状態だと
そういうふうに書いているのは
いかにこれをこそ これだけは難しいと
他のところはものすごい明確に分析して説明しているんだけどね
そういうことで この難しいんですね
で お釈迦様のお経は全部覚えていらっしゃった
アナンタ尊者ですか  そのアナンダ尊者もまあよく仏教は理解はしていたんだけど
その人もある日はまあ
十二因縁というのはまあ分かりやすいではないかと
難しいと思いますけど
みんなまあなんか私から考えれば分かりやすいんだと言ったら
お釈迦様はそれに もう答えて
そんなことを言ってはいけませんと
十二因縁の話は いわゆる因縁法則の話
十二因縁ではなくて 因縁の法則の話は簡単だと言ってはいけませんと
世の中ではこれこそ難しいですよ
理解するのは 人々はこの理解できなくて
迷いに迷っているんだと
存在 生命として これでまあ
何といいますか いろいろ美しい例え
いくらかありますけど
なんかこの大きな森の中にもいきなり入り込んじゃっても
どっちも方向も何もわからないように迷っているような状態で迷っているんだと
で そこを分かれば 理解できれば
みんなこの存在の問題を解決して解脱するんだろうと
というふうに アナンダ尊者にさえ
お釈迦様は軽々く言うなと軽いと思うなとは言っているんです
で それはそれ それは因縁の話
何か因縁の話なんですけど
何か仏教の後の時代になってくると
ああ これは十二因縁だ
十二因縁だと 十二因縁に固まっているんですね
それで人が十二因縁に固まっているんだから
私たちにも十二の話をしなさいと
と言うんです だから十二因縁は十二だから
それを覚えておけばそれで十分ですけどね
それは簡単に覚えられますけどね
それで因果の話を勉強したことにはならないんですね
で それからまあですから
そこで理解していただきたいというのは
まあ大変大きな話であって
たまたま十二因縁に一つだけ説明しているだけ
ですから 因縁の話は確実に十二因縁に限るものではありません
もっと大きい話なんです
それ一つ理解していただきたいです
次に 日本語の問題があります
で 日本語でこれもなんとかいいんですよとかね
というふうな この なんかの因縁でしょうというふうな話も出てくるんですね
この我々の日常生活でなんとかいいんですよ
これはもうなんとかの因縁ですよと
という その言葉と また我々は脱出しなくちゃいけないんですね
それは日本語としては別に問題ないんだけど
その意味自体が仏教の因縁の話というのはあまりにも良くない
間違ってるんですね 私たちは変なことが考えているんだからといって
お釈迦様は同じことを考えなくちゃいけないんだよと思うのは
もう酒を飲みたくない人に酒を勧めることと同じなんですよ
それはすごい失礼なんですね
で 普通の日本では まあなんかいいことに出会ったら
いい人に会いたい人に出会ったら
これはなんとかいいんだよと言うんですよ
ただ それだけの意味で
それより深い意味がないんです
なんとか縁でしょうと
その中でも自分としてはわからないんですけど
まあ一応ある面では避けられないも状態
ですからいいと言ってしまっちゃうんですね
それから不幸に出会ったら因縁というんですね
で いいことに出会ったらいいと言うんです
なんかいいんですよと
何か不幸に出会ったら
あ これなんとか因縁でしょうとかいうような感じがするんですね
ですから その場合も 自分にはちょっと逆らうことはできなかったんだけど
もうなんかちょっとした不幸に出会ったと
それに因縁というと ですから
それは説明してよと私に頼んだっても
はっきり言ってほしいんですね
それだったら 日本では不幸に出会ったらいいという
まあ幸福な何かいいことにあったらいいと言うんだと
それだったら私にこう聞けばいいんですね
なぜ人々がたまにいいことに出会いますかと
いい人に巡り合うし いいチャンスに巡り合うし
それはなぜでしょうかと聞いた方が正しいんです
因縁の話をしてくれというのはもうおかしいんですね
あるいは不幸に出会ったら
なんか悪い因縁でしょうとおっしゃるでしょうね
それ知りたければ なぜ人が悪いことに出会いますかと
なぜ不幸になるかと説明してくださいと言ったならば
そこら辺は説明できます
それはどっちもしないで
じゃあ仏教の因縁の話を説明してくださいと
説明できないので その場合は言葉は間違っているんですね
ですから この無責任で言葉を使ってはいけないんです
で 言葉ではもう何でも表現できませんだけど
我々人間に互いに話し合うために
コミュニケーションするために一番
一番大事な道具一つは言葉なんですね
それはむやみに無責任で使うとかなりダメージを受けますよ
ですから この言葉というのは何か意味を持っているし
それで言葉っていうのはもう確実にその意味を持っているわけでもないんです
ある枠組みで一つの意味を持っちゃうし
ある枠で違う意味を持っちゃうし
例えば科学者も我々使っている同じ言葉使っているし
我々も普通に同じ言葉使っているし
だからといって我々科学者になるかというと
そうはならないし 意味が違うんですね
で それから同じ言葉 例えば子供が使うと
女性の方々が使うと 会社で使うと
授業に使うと ある専門分野で使うとかね
それなりに言葉の意味が変わるんですね
ですから どんな枠の中で我々は言葉を使うかということも気をつけなくちゃ
もう理解できないんですね
で まあもう一つ例で言うならば
この文学 詩なんか書く場合も言葉を使うんですね
その 例えば詩を書いた人が
まあ空は限りなく美しいと言うかもしれません
それは詩ですから間違ってないんです
そこである人が まあ空のことを科学者が講義しようとするところで
空は限りなく美しいでしょうと
その人に聞いたっても意味がないんです
その人にとっては限りないというのは違う意味を持ってるんですよ
空間的に無制限という意味を持ってるんですね
空ということは違う また全く違う意味を持ってるんですね
同じ言葉なんですけど
ですから 自分がどんな枠の中で言葉を使っているんですかと気をつけないと
もう大変混乱するし 互いに話は通じなくなっちゃうし
ですから どんな立場で
例えば科学者にも詩書けますよ
科学者が詩を書いちゃったら
科学の論文にはならないんです
それは それはあくまでも詩だから
感覚的に この自分の感情ですか
それを表していることだから
ですから それとあれを混ぜたら
まあどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでこの釈尊のある立場なんですけど
人々は何か話し合いになってくると
お釈迦様はいつでもこう聞くんですね
あなたは あの 認めるべきことはきちんと認めるならば
否定するべきことはきちんと否定するならば
それから言葉はもうまずきちんと使うならば
もし私が使っている言葉の意味がわからない場合は
この言葉はどういう意味か
どういう意味かとちゃんと意味を聞いてもらうならば
私はあなたと話しますと
そうでないと会話になれ立たないんですよ
例えばお釈迦様は何か言葉を使う
その人は自分勝手に解釈する
例えばお釈迦様は真理の立場で一切は空という
その聞いている人が日常生活の立場で
ああ そうかなと思うかもしれませんし
違いますよと言うかもしれませんし
結構人生は楽しいですよと
あんた嘘を言ってるんだと言うかもしれません
そうすると話にならないんです
ですから お釈迦様は一切は空であると言ったならば
空ってどういう意味ですか？と
一切はどういう意味ですか？と釈尊に聞かなくちゃいけない
それ自分勝手に 自分が奥さんと子供たちと仲良くしていることは一切だと思う
勘違いしたっても それで困るんですよ
ですから 自分たち自分だけの世界に閉じ込めないで
相手がどんな次元で どんな枠の中で言葉を使っているか
どんな定義かと 毎日聞いている言葉にしたっても
気をつけなくちゃいけない
ですから この言葉について
仏教はその点では結構うるさいんです
すごく気をつけるんです
で まあそういういろいろ
この因果法則の説明の場合はね
そういうもういろいろ基本的に覚えておかなくちゃ
注意がたくさんなるんです
そうでないとちょっと難しいんですね
とにかく立派な人間に
しっかりした人間に 知恵が毎日育てられる人間になりたければ
こういう条件は覚えておいた方がいいんですよ
きちんと人が言うことをすぐそのまま鵜呑みするんじゃなくて
その相手が何を考えているかということも理解する必要ありますよ
例えば 私はもう人間のこと大嫌いだと人が言ったところで
ああそうですかじゃなくて
それはその人その場で人間だと何を思っているかと
大嫌いだと何を考えて思っているかと
きちんと聞いた方がいいんです
例えば その人の意見を破りたくなったと
私は人間のこと大嫌いだという人のこと
違いますよと自分で言いたいんです
違いますと言ったところで喧嘩になるんです
違います いえ 私は大嫌いだと
え それは違う あなたはいくら違いますよと
私は嫌いだから嫌いですと言っちゃったら
そこで話にならないでしょうに
ですから 言葉を知っている人は
その場合はこういうふうに話を進めるんですよ
攻撃する場合も じゃああなたは人間は嫌いだと
よくわかりましたと で
なぜ嫌いですか？と あるいは嫌いというのはどういうふうに嫌いですかと
どういう意味ですかと
とその人に聞けば あるいは人間嫌いという結論
結論をなぜ出したかと
その過程を言ってくださいと言ったところで
その人は何を考えているかということがわかるんですね
例えばそれで見つかるんですね
なんとか人 なんとか人
なんとか人 その人を裏切ったとかね
あるいはなんとかなんとか人に
その人 随分希望して頼っていたんだと
そこで全部その希望はなくなって
人は裏切れたと あるいは自分がすごい信頼していた人の
あの 何て言います 借金の何になりますか
保証人ですかになったと
で 借金 今まではもう大変仲のいい友達でしたけど
借金のことに保証人としてサインした
その日からもう口もきかないで
どこかへ出て行っちゃったと
自分がもう全部借金を払わなく払わなくちゃいけないことになったんだということを言うかもしれません
で そこでその人の考え方
すぐ壊せますよ あなたはある人に保証人になって
それであなたは大変悲しいことに
大変いけないことに出会いましたと
それで人間嫌いというと
世界中すべての人間が借金の保証人になったならば
みんな逃げるんですかと
ただ そうではないでしょうに
ですから たまたまあなたが不幸にあったんだからといって
すべての人間が悪魔とは言えませんと
というふうに その人の論想
考え方を直そうやら壊そうやら
何でもいいんだけど できますよ
それできるなのは 相手が何を考えて
どんな結論に どのように
なっているかという過程と言葉の定義
言葉を使っている このディストリビューションって
いわゆる枠の枠 それを理解している時なんですね
そういうふうに言うと
すごい難しい話に聞こえますけど
やっぱり仏教ではいつでもそういう立場で話しているんですよ
無責任で感情的に言葉は使わない
それはもう喧嘩の元で
不幸の元で理解全くなくなることになります
余計な話はそこら辺にして
じゃあ無明の話に入ります
で 日本でよく知っている 12円の話では
12円の話は因果の話だと思ってますけど
因果の話は 12円だけではない
もっとすごい大きい話なんです
それから じゃあ因果の話の一つである 12円の場合は
12円は一番最初に無明という言葉から始まります
で 無明という言葉はパーリ語でアウィッジャと言うんですね
アウィッジャっていうのはこの否定形の言葉で
これは肯定の言葉はア抜けちゃったらヴィッジャという言葉で出ております
ヴィッジャにアつけたらアウィッジャになるんですね
ヴィッジャっていうのはもう
知恵なんですね これは目覚めた状態でも我々定義する知恵
それから一般のパーリ語サンスクリット語では
ヴィッジャというのはサイエンスなんです
でも サイエンスという意味ではこの場合は使いません
その場合はもう目が覚めましたという意味なんで
ヴィッジャといえば 目が覚めましたと
知恵が現れましたと もしヴィッジャは知恵が現れた状態であるならば
誰でもどんな状態にいますかというと
アウィッジャの状態にいるんです
ですから ヴィッジャっていうのは特別な状態
目が覚めた状態 真理を発見した状態
真実を知った状態 ヴィッジャの状態なんですね
ですから 生命は生まれつき真理を発見しているんだと言ったら
それちょっと合わない話でしょう
ということは 生命は普通にいる状態はアウィッジャ状態
アウィッジャっていうのは日本語で無明という専門用語を使っているんですね
明りはないという言葉を書いてますけどね
ですから 我々の普通の状態に無明というんです
そこで我々は何とかの方法で努力して
この一切の真理はそのままありのまま正しく理解し
発見したならば その心の状態にヴィッジャと言うんです
ですから ヴィッジャという状態が特別な状態で
アウィッジャ無明というのは普通な生命の普通な状態なんですね
で 初期仏教では人は本来悟っていますよとか
そういう証拠もない観念的なことは言わない
で 私もそんな反対するのは良くないんだけど
私さえこの本来悟っているよという方々に直接聞かないと
私も間違いを起こせますよ
勝手に解釈すれば 一応耳には入っているし
いろんな本には書いてはあります
その文章だけは それで私は勝手に解釈するんだけど
それはあくまでも私の勝手な解釈であって
勝手な批判であって だからその言ってる方々に本来みんな如来であって悟っているんだと
ブッダですよと言うならば
それはどういうことで
どういうわけでそうおっしゃいますか？おっしゃいますかと
その方々に聞いて 定義をちゃんといただいてない限り反論はできないんです
そこで釈尊の立場から見れば
ヴィッジャの状態っていうのは
人は何らかの方法で努力して頑張って真理を知るようにする
すべてのことを生命のこと
宇宙のこと 何でもいいんだけど
一切のからくりをありのまま正しく理解しようとする
それで理解する 理解したならば
その状態にヴィッジャとも言うし
悟りとも言うし もう如来でも何でもいいんです
その場合は言葉だけだったら
ですから 初期仏教にとってはもうヴィッジャ妙知恵というのは大変な努力の結果でありますね
そういう特別な努力は何もしない
うちは我々は無明アヴィッジャの状態にいるんです
それで努力しても悟ってない限りはアヴィッジャなんですね
無明なんですね そこで我々はちょっと間違うところがあります
アヴィッジャのいろいろ同義語ございます
一つの同義語っていうのは無知なんですね
あの智慧がない意味で
アヴィッジャイコール無明イコール無知なんですね
そこで無知という言葉を使ったら
パーリ語でモハと言うんだけど
あの貪瞋痴の痴なんですね
で ちょっと問題を起こすんです
どういう問題かというと
あんた無知でしょうと言った途端に
その人を批判したことになっちゃうんですね
貶されたことになっちゃうんですね
なんか機嫌が悪くなっちゃうんです
で 無知と同じでしょうに
愚かさ 日本語で言えばバカとかね
そういう言葉全部だいたい頭が悪いって意味なんですよ
結局同義語なんですけど
だからもういい加減で
どっち使ってもいいんですよ
どっち使ってもいいんだけど
人々が すべての生命は無知だ
アホやというのはなんか失礼な言い方ではないかと
仏教のと思い込む 思ってしまうんですね
そこでどういうトラブルかというと
自分の定義を持ってるんですね
モハの自分なりの定義
この自分なりの定義 仏教の言葉に当てはめてみようとする
そう合わなくなっちゃうんですね
で 仏教では無明といってアヴィッジャと言って
誰も貶をしているわけじゃないんです
ただ単にある真理を語ろうとしているだけ
ある科学的な法則を解明しようとしているだけ
例えば科学者はもう医学者ががんのことやら
食べ物のことやら いろんなことを研究したりすると
あれ 我々貶してるんですかね
タバコもあんまりも吸い過ぎだったら肺がんになりますよと言うと
お医者さんには誰も怒りませんよ
なぜかというと その人はいろいろ研究して
して もう一日四十分ぐらいタバコを吸ったら
もう十年経っちゃうと
もう肺がんにこれぐらい肺がんになったケースがありますよとかね
ただ事実を言うだけで
美味しくタバコ吸ってる私をバカにするんではない
この医者が とか思わないんですね
ですから この言葉ではそういうふうに感情が入っちゃったらちょっと問題になります
ですから このテキストでは我々のアヴィッジャイコールモハとちゃんと書いてますよ
ちゃんと書いてますけど
説明に入るとやっぱりアヴィッジャという無明という言葉をとって
その中で説明を続けていくんです
でも 仏教のことを知っている人は
全然もうそういうことを聞いても腹が立ったりはしません
人間のことを呼ぶ場合は
お釈迦様がよく使う言葉というのは
愚か者という言葉なんです
それで全然昔の人々 それいくら聞いたっても全然腹が立つと気持ち悪くなるなるっていうこと全くないんです
なぜならば真理を語っているんだから
お釈迦様にとって愚か者っていうのは
あの 一生懸命努力して悟ることに頑張っていない
まだ成功していない ただそれだけのことですから
それは学生ということと同じなんですよ
学生と言った途端 もう勉強まだ終わってないという意味でしょうに
まだまだ未熟という意味でしょうね
ある面で見れば 私は学生ですよというのは
私はまだまだ未熟ですよと
まだ勉強中ですよと まだやることいっぱいあるんだと
まだ一人前じゃないということだから
だから学生と言ったところで
殴さ 殴られた 殺されたということは誰もないでしょうに
あんた学生さんでしょうと人に聞いても
若い人に殴られたと はないでしょう
それは決して人を貶す言葉じゃないんです
差別用語じゃないんです
ですから 仏教の愚か者という言葉が決して差別用語じゃないんです
日本語の愚か者は差別用語であるかもしれませんだけど
パーリ語の愚か者にある言葉が
全然差別用語じゃないんです
単なる学生という感じで
同じそんなレベルの言葉なんです
ですから 修行中の人にだけを仏教では学生と呼ぶんです
一生懸命修行している
その人に学生と ですから皆様
日本は仏教用語で聞いたことありますね
有学無学と この有学というのは学生っていう意味なんですね
いわゆる学問はまだまだ学問ではなくて
学ぶものはありと 無学っていうのは学ぶものはなしと
いわゆる修了しましたという意味なんですね
でも日本語はどうですか？日本語で無学っていうのは全く勉強してないっていう意味なんでしょうね
一般の日本語では だから一般日本語でこうだったからといって
もう我々にはどうしようもないんです
同じ言葉を使わなくちゃいけないんだから
まあ違う枠組みで使ってるんですよとぐらい理解してほしい
それで仏教ではなんで修行中の人にだけ学生
あるいは有学と言いますかというと
その人はこの特別な道を
特別な方法を実験しようとしているんですよ
真理に目覚める 真理に目覚める特別な方法
じゃあやってみようと
ですから その人は研究中であって
もう真理を探検中なんですね
そこで探検していけば
確実に真理に出会う ですから
彼だけは学生であって
修行しようとしない方々は別に仏教では有学という言葉には入らないんです
ですから 仏教の用語で有学というと
修行中の人々 無学といえば修行を完成した悟った人々
他の人々誰一人も入らない
そういうふうに この一応言葉の言葉も問題解決しながら
アヴィッジャのことを説明してみましょう
ですから アヴィッジャっていうのは
我々の普通な状態 と我々だけじゃないんです
すべての生命の普通な状態
神々のもの アヴィッジャない人っていうのは
もう修行して真理に出会って
悟りを開いて 一切の煩悩をなくして解脱している人
その人はヴィッジャ それでお釈迦様が悟った時
悟りをどのように表現したかというと
ヴィッジャウデパーディという言葉を使ったんです
ヴィッジャウデパーディ
ヴィッジャーというものがウダパーティというのは現れましたと
現れましたと ヴィッジャーウデーパーティ
ですというのは知恵が現れましたと
いわゆる目が目覚めたと
目が覚めましたと いわゆる真理を知ったとわかりましたという意味なんです
ですから 釈尊は今の人類の中で初めて悟り開いた方だから
で ただ その場合はたった釈尊一人だけアヴィッジャーがなかったんです
それからお釈迦様から道を教えて悟った方々も
その何人かだけアヴィッジャーがなくて
他の生命はみんなアヴィッジャーなんです
ということで 決してこれは差別用語でも機嫌が悪くなる必要もない
ごく普通の科学的な言葉だとまず理解しておいてください
それを理解していただければ
まあ私なりに皆さんに役に立つような話に戻りますけど
で じゃあこれから無明の説明いたします
で 無明あるいは無知 まあ知恵がない状態
で 我々には知恵がないんだと
いわゆる普通に言えば愚か者だと
何も知らんだと 真理は
いくら人が修行して 仏教ではなくて
他の宗教でいろんな修行をしていたっても
いくら真面目に頑張っても
どんな勉強したっても
どんな天才であろうとも
お釈迦様に話 愚か者と喋るんです
馬鹿者扱いされているんですね
で それはどういうことかと
じゃあ私たちは普通にすごい知識を持っている
宇宙のことは宇宙の果てまで知っているんだと
ありとあらゆる科学方程式に沿って
いろんな機械を使って知ったから
から お釈迦様のところに行ったら
この馬鹿者と喋る 何もわかってない馬鹿者やと言うかもしれません
まあそうや 直接言わないんだけど
一応言えないわけでもないんです
仏教においては 我々人間のどんな知識であろうとも
全部一つのヴィッジャーに入れてくれない
全部アヴィッジャーに入れてくれる
で どういうことかというと
たとえ天才中の天才であろうとも
普通の人間にできることなんですね
それは 我々天才というのは
一般的な人間にはまあちょっとできない
早くやるんです 例えば大学ぐらいまでの勉強はすぐ
小学生の時の時で終わってしまっちゃったら
天才だというんです それはスピードが早い
そこで人が 20 秒で走る距離がある
人は 10 秒で走っちゃったら
あの人は天才だという
だからスポーツの世界にも天才たちがいて
音楽の世界にも天才たちがいて
勉強の学問の世界にも天才たちがいるんです
科学の世界にも天才という人々はいるんです
それはまあスピードが速い
でしょ で 例えば素晴らしい音楽を書くと
ある人は一生をかけて
もう苦労して苦労して一つの作品を作ると
あれとは何のことなくピアノをぶん殴っている途中で
もうさっさっさと書いてしまったと
それですごい時間が早いんですよ
それで早く書いた人は天才であって
それには 20年かかった人は普通の音楽家なんですね
まあ天才っていうのは
大雑把に言えばね それはもう完璧な定義ではないんだけど
スピードが速いということにはなるんですけどね
で 我々仏教の立場から見れば
それ全てこの真理を発見する道じゃないんですね
例えば いかに音楽の天才
超天才であろうとも どんな人間にもできないほど
1000年経っても  2000年経っても
どんな人間にも発見できないほどの素晴らしい音楽を作っても
それはあくまでも音楽の音の世界であって
何か真理を発見したわけじゃないんです
で そういう天才たちが未だに我々を乗り越えられないね
例えば中国の鍼治療であろうか
気功であろうか そういうのを発見した人々がすごいでしょうね
我々は中国の 5000年の歴史
ああだこうだと言いながら
ただそれを受けているだけ
現代人が なぜあちこち体中に針刺しちゃったら病気が治るかとさっぱりわからないんですね
わからないんだけど あっちこっち針をさせてもらって
ヨーロッパでもやりますし
自分の国でも病院でやるんですよ
一般の人にはやるなと
もう国がもう禁じられているんです
日本では医者でなくてもできますけど
自分の国ではちゃんとした医者でないと
あれ 免許証をもらわないんです
で そういう差はちょっとありますけど
それは安全のために 日本だったら同じ文化だから
別にそれは別に気にしなくてもいいんだけど
向こうは文化違うんだから
人々は勝手にあちこち体中に刺したりするようになっちゃったらね
無責任で それは危ないんだから
もうやめなさいと もう教訓はない
やったらまあちゃんとそれに対罰あり
体罰というんですか 罰ですからね
で でも こんなに科学発展してあっても
今医学を発展してあるにも関わらず
どういうわけか どういう原因か
どういう法則か さっぱりまるっきりわからない
それで今の人々はこの針を入れる場所は全部暗記して
どんなどんな組み合わせで針を入れた方がいいかという
これそれだけ勉強して針を刺すだけ
そこで私たちに見えるのは
そういうのを発見した人々がいかに偉大なる天才たちでしょうね
これぐらい年取っているのにも
それ乗り越えられない
乗り越えるどころか この法則さえ発見していない
こんなにも科学物理学を発見しているのに
発展しているのに だから天才っていうのは
そういうもうとてつもない天才たちもこの世の中にいましたし
そういう人が 例えば針の方法を発見した人がお釈迦様のところに行ったならば
あんたは本当におろか者で
何もわかっていないと言うかもしれません
それは仏教の立場なんですね
なぜかというと その人々が体のからくりをわかっただけのことなんですね
それでどこか痛いんだったら痛みを治す
どこか機能しないと 例えば足が硬くて動かない
ルー麻痺で針をさせてもらったら
もうすぐ 10 分で歩けると
西洋医学では難しいんですけど
そういう風にこのいろいろ体の故障直し
ですから 仏教から見れば体の修理屋さんであって
これすごい素晴らしい上手な修理屋さんですよ
ですから そこも心理の次元に行ってないんですね
ですから そういうことで
私たちの知識は そういうもう誰にも乗り越えられないほどの
とてつもない素晴らしい天才たちの知識であろうか
仏教から見れば もう一つの知識に過ぎないとというふうな状態になります
じゃあ これからなんでそんな失礼なことを仏教は言いますかと
そこら辺のことを説明させていただきます
で それからはお釈迦様の智慧の立場から喋らなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様はこの私は存在するんだ
心が存在するんだ ものは存在するんだ
宇宙は存在するんだ 神様が存在するんだという
この存在するんだ 存在しているんだ
いるんだ いるんだ いるんだという
あまりもうるさくて みんなもうあるという話ばっかりしてるんですね
ここで私がいるんじゃないかと
私がいるんだから皆様はいるんじゃないかと
ということは 我々の親分たる神もいるんじゃないかと
ここに私がいるということは
神様が存在するという同じことだと
説明するんですよ 例えば
ここに私がいます それは真実だ
私がいるんだから 私がいるということが真実であるならば
私の目の前に住んでいらっしゃる皆様方も本当にいる
存在しているということは
もっと広げてみれば すべてのものもきちんと存在している
ということは まあ存在の元としてまとめて考えたら神は存在している
じゃあこれから一斉にみんなその神様を拝みましょうと
またそれから宗教は始まります
そういうすべてがあるあるあるという
存在している 存在しているという
その哲学しか一つもこの世の中にないんです
それはまあ 仏教用語であるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
私は有論だと 有というあるという漢字を書いて有論だと
まあ勝手に言葉をつけてますけどね
で パーリ語の言葉が一つあります
アッティワーダ アッティワーダ
アッティっていうのはあるということ
いるということ 存在するという意味なんですね
アッティ で このアッティという言葉は英語にしちゃうと IS
ハーフ その 2つも入るんですね
で この場合はビーンですね
ある  exist という意味で使うんですね
存在 だからワーダっていうのは論
世の中にあるのは全部アッティワーダ
有論ばっかしなんです
じゃあものはないないという人に出会ったことがありますか？誰かが
私はここでいません あなたもここにいませんとかね
この地球もありませんと
太陽もありませんと 何もないんだと
話はもう話にならないんですね
その場合は ですから お釈迦様の時代で
インドのどこを見ても
ありとあらゆる形でこの有論をみんな喋ってるんです
それである人々があまりもうるさいんだから
有論を喋ってるんだから
無論喋り始めたんですね
ないと 何もないんだ 私もいません
あなたもだから故にあなたもいません
ですから存在もいませんと
ということで神もいませんと
で それで有論に対して無論が生まれたんですが
そこでまた問題があるんですね
私もいませんと言いながら
その人が喋ってるし 私はいませんという人がなんで他人に私はいませんと言うんですかね
言う必要ないでしょうに
聞く相手がいないんだから
私は存在しない だからあなたも存在しませんし
他人も存在しませんし
僕はこのこの 3つの 3つの順番が
このドイツの哲学者のビューバービューバーブーバーですか
彼の考え方から借りていってるんです
なぜならば 神をきちんと証明しようと頑張ったのはその人ですから
自分一人ではよく証明したと思っている
彼がこのイシュとダウト
ジーという言葉 3つですね
I You アンド He そういう言葉は単なる言葉のカラクリなんですけどね
言葉のカラクリと言ったって
我々の理解のカラクリでもありますから
それを大事に使っているんですね
私がという言葉は そこにあなたという言葉成り立つし
その両方から離れたら彼らというものは成り立つんだと
他ですね 他が成り立つんだと
そこで私がいるんだから
ですからもう当然ながらあなたもいると
当然ながら彼らもいるんだと
そこで私とあなたといったら完全な関係できちゃいますからね
完璧な関係できちゃうんですね
私とあなたっていうのは
これ他に誰もないっていう意味ですから
そこで神様っていうのは私とあなたですから
そこで神様は存在するということがいろいろ
言ってるような感じがしましたからね
で インドではそうってもっと違いましたから
ある有論喋ってるんだから
まあずっともうないという人々も現れちゃって
そのないという人々の場合はものすごく矛盾見えちゃって
だから私は今言ってる矛盾なんですね
私がいないと言ったら
ここでいないんだから
他人もいないし 他人に喋る必要はないし
喋っても他人が理解するわけでもないし
いないものだから それでなんで世の中で無論喋って走り回ったかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
全部無と本当にわかったならば
一言も喋らないはずなんですけど
ですから それは単なる有論に対する頭の中で来た反論
そこで釈尊がこうおっしゃる
世の中を見ると 一応有論か一応無論か
それだけですよと お釈迦様はそれはどこにも納得いかなかったんですね
私がいるいると言っても
この みんな言語下手だから
言葉っていうのは無責任に使うんだから
真剣に言葉で考えちゃうと
そこでこの矛盾見つかっちゃうんですね
なぜならば 赤ちゃんが思う私がいると
青年がまた私がいると思う
中年がまた私がいると思う
それで老人がまた私がいると思うでしょうし
そのそれぞれの人 それぞれの場合で
私という言葉に入る意味が違うんじゃないかと
私という言葉に入る意味ですね
これは赤ちゃんが私という時の私と
青年が私という私が内容は違うんでしょうし
ですから私がいる 私がいるとずっと言いっぱなし
言葉だけ ラベリングだけ
ラベルだけ ずっと同じラベルなんです
中身は違う だから同じ瓶にいろんなものを入れちゃう
それでみんな同じだと勘違いすると
例えばある瓶を持ってきて
そこに何かラベルを貼る
醤油とか まあ醤油じゃなくて
何か他のわかりやすい何か入れたってもいいんだけど
まあ例えば水だとラベリングする
そこでもう一人が来て
ちゃんとその瓶の水を入れ替えて灯油を入れちゃう
でもボトルは水とラベルありますから
もう一人の人が来て それに透明なアルコールを入れるかもしれません
それでボトルを見て あ
これはまあ 水だと勘違いすることだけではないけど
中身は違うんだから それで私というこの言葉というのは
入れ物で考えちゃうと
その場でその場で言う私が違うでしょうし
中身が ですから いるということにはちょっと納得いかないんですね
いわゆる変化しているんだから
例えば花が存在しているんだと言うと
花見ているとつぼみの状態がありまして
その前もつぼみの前にもう枝の中にもう現れてない状態があって
つぼみがあって 咲いている状態があって
一部枯れてる状態があって
全部枯れてる状態があって
全部花びらが落ちてる状態があったりして
その中にどんな瞬間の状態花ですかと
というと ある瞬間は花と言えるんであって
他の瞬間は他の言葉ではないでしょうか
花の場合はそうわかるんだけど
人間 自分の場合は言葉を変えないんですね
この前も同じ例を言ったんだけど
人間には 1 日に違う名前で言うならば結構問題ないと思いますよ
今日は田中ですけど 明日は田村ですと
で なぜならば 昨日の来た同じ人は今日はいませんだから
花びらと同じく変化していくんですね
ですから お釈迦様は人間そこは考えていないんだと
そこで無論の場合も何もない
何もないといっても 何もないと言ったっても
今すでにここに喋っているわ
体が疲れたら痛いわ 病気になったら痛いわ
美しい人が見たら何かすごい気持ちがよくなっちゃうし
あまり見たくない人が見ると気持ちが悪くなっちゃうし
会いたい人に会ったら
ものすごく体で体中もう暖か暖か暖かくなっても気持ちよくなっちゃうし
で 会いたくない人が強引に部屋に入っちゃうと
もう追い出せないんだから
すごく心の中で嫌で嫌でという
もう実際に我々にとってはそういう世界だから
これ一概にないと言えますかと
ですから ないという立場も取らない
あるという立場も取らない
その代わりに 一時的に現象が現れて
その条件変えたらその現象が消えちゃって
次の条件にふさわしい違う現象が現れるんだと
全てはそういう風に流れていると言ったら
もうきちんと自分には納得いくし
わかるし で ある時はもう
赤ちゃんである その時は正真正銘の赤ちゃんで
その細胞を変化して違う細胞が生まれる
心も変化して違う心になる
それで青年という現象が現れる
それまた一時的で ずっとその状態ではなくて
また条件変えていっちゃいますから
青年作った条件すぐ変わりますから
違う人が現れてくる ですから
その瞬間瞬間でいろんな条件
因縁が揃って その時一時的な現象が現れる
映画を見る時でも同じことでしょうに
いくらあの投影する機械があっても
そこに映画というものは成り立たない
フィルムを持ってきても
映画というものは成り立たない
フィルムを機械に入れたっても
これは必死になって手ででも回しちゃっても
映画っていうことに成り立たない
そこでスクリーンがあって
正しくフィルムを機械に入れて電源を入れて
もう回したところで 機械の法則によって
そこでありとあらゆる原因が揃うんですね
そこでスクリーンにある光が映っちゃう
それでも映画というものは成り立たない
そこに人間がいて それを光を見ると
見て頭の中でそれをずっと解釈する
ストーリーを頭の中で作る
スクリーンからストーリーを仰ってくれるわけじゃないんですね
その頭の中でストーリーを作ったところで
映画ということは成り立ちますよ
そこでどこかの原因が消えちゃったら全部消えちゃう
誰かが原因 電源を切ったと
あるいはプロジェクターの光を出している場所部分がありますからね
ライトみたいなもの それ切れたと
あるいはこの機械のビウスが消えちゃったと
あるいはスクリーンが落っこっちゃったと
何でもいいんです そこで映画は成り立たない
あるいは人が撮影機 撮影じゃなくて投影機の前を通ったと
ちょうど自分の体的前
自分前を通っただけでもう映画消えちゃいますから
そういうわずかな原因が変化したっても
そこで映画ということ現象が消えちゃう
ですから 原因が揃ったら一時的な現象が現れて
その原因が消えちゃったらその現象が消えちゃってしまう
消えてしまう そこにもし違う原因があったら
違うものは現れる という話は因縁の話であって
中道とも言うんです ですから
有論は極論であると 無論も極論であると
ブッダは有論無論乗り越えて中道にとって説法するんだと
ですから 仏教の説法は全部中道でありまして
中道でもいいし 中論でもいいんですけど
因果説もあります でもあります
普通日本で言ってる因縁の話ではないんです
仏教の説法すべてが因果の話なんです
うん まあそこも言わなきゃアヴィッチャーに入れませんだからもうなかなか
で そこでなぜ我々にアヴィッチャーと言うんですか？なぜ我々は無明を持ってるんですかと
なぜ努力しなきゃ悟らないんですか？と
そこに宇宙の法則があるんですね
で 何かを知るという働きがあるんですね
そこに生命になるんですね
知ることで生命なんです
認識する 感じる 全部知ることなんですね
ですから この空き缶は生命だとは私たちには言えません
空き缶は何か知ってるかどうか分かりませんだから
環境に反応はするんだけど
知識的に認識的には反応しない
で 我々はそうじゃなくて
寒い時は寒さ感じる 暖かい時は暖かいと感じる
悲しいと感じる 楽しいと感じる
ものを知る で ゴキブリもアリもそうやって環境は知っているんですね
ですから そういうのは生命なんですね
ですから 生命というのは知ることなんですね
知る機能がついていると
そこに生命というんです
で そういうのはこの まあちゃんとした仏教的な定義で覚えていらっしゃれば大変役に立ちます
生命といった途端 我々はなんか大雑把で文学的に考えちゃうんですね
それで宗教もなんだかんだでものすごく混乱状態で
話し合うことできなくなっちゃって
わけもわからなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから この言葉は気をつけた方がいい
文学的に喋るところは文学だけで
哲学を喋るところは哲学だけで
ごちゃまぜにしちゃったら困ると
科学喋るところは科学的にと
まあそういうことで 仏教ではまあまあ
生命は偉大なりとか 生命はありがたいとか尊いとか
そういう大雑把な言葉を置いておいて
生命を定義する場合は
知る機能 まあそれは生命と取っているんですね
それで知るためには 外の世界と我々
やっぱり触れなくちゃいけないんですね
で 例えば太陽があると知るためには
太陽と私が出会わなくちゃいけないんです
ぶつからなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで太陽がある形で
私にも太陽そのままぶつかる
ぶつかっちゃったら知ることができませんだけど
太陽の光が目を通って私の体に触れる
ぶつかる それで太陽があると我々は知ってるんです
それに知識で言うんですね
悟りではなくて それのカラクリはこういうカラクリなんですね
私の 目がここになかったならば
光が触れても目にぶつからないんですね
そこで光がなかったならば
そこでぶつかるものはないんですね
そうすると太陽があるということは言えないんですよ
で 太陽があるということは
目があったことと光があったこととぶつかったことなんです
でも それで人間が判断するゆえに私がいる
太陽があると なぜならばあったんだからぶつかったんですよ
と でももうちょっと観察すると
太陽はもう変化していく
自分も変化していく すべてのものは変化して変わっていく
ですから 一概にあると言えますかと
で それで私はもう今最近よく言ってる説明方法なんですけど
仏教においてはものはそういう変化するんだから
変化することは厳密に見るとある波動になってしまっちゃうんですね
ものは波動になって ある瞬間とない瞬間両方
持ってるんですね であるとないとあるとないと
仏教ではそれはまあ ウッパとバンガという専門用語を使ってますけど
現れることと消えること
生と滅 生と滅と ものは生と生
生 それから滅す 消える
その波動でありますと
で 花を見てください 花が消えなくちゃいけないし
消えたところで実が出てくるんだから
でも 残念ながら私たちにはあ
花消えちゃったということは体験できないんですね
花がどんどん変わって実になること過程は見えますけど
あるものを消える瞬間は見えないんですね
本当は消えなくちゃ 次の場が現れないんです
映画のスクリーンに一つの映像コマが消えなきゃ
そのまま残っていると
次の映像は映らないんです
そこで花が消えない場合は
どうやってそこに実が現れますかね
赤ちゃんが消えてくれなきゃ
どうやって子供が現れますかね
本当は私たちのものは消える瞬間もあります
あるんだけど それは残念ながら見えない
わからない 感じない そこで私の赤ちゃんが子供になったと思っちゃいますね
いつなったんですか？と聞いたらわからないでしょ
私は年取りました いつ年取ったんですかと
で あの漫画なんかね 映像化する場合は
アニメーションにする場合は
その現象はちゃんとあるんですよ
例えば一つの絵をビデオに撮って
次の映像をビデオに撮る
次の映像をビデオに撮り
それを流しておくとアニメーションだと勘違いする
私たちはアニメーションは正しいと思ってるだけ
本当はアニメーションそこにがあるんじゃなくて
一つ一つ描いた絵が消えて消えていくだけでしょ
それでアニメーションを作る時
使う原理が全ての存在にある原理なんです
で そう言うとわかりにくいんですが
まあどうしようもないんです
わかりにくいことだっても
ですから わかりやすくします
で 目があるとしましょう
目がありますと そこで目に見える対象があるんだと
そこで目は現れて消えて現れて消えて現れて消えてという
ずっと流れていくんだと
目といっても 個体的な目というものがあるんじゃなくて
現れて消えて現れて消えて現れて消えて動いている
そこで見る対象もそういうふうに現れて消えて現れて消えて現れて消えて動いている
そこで目がそのものを見ようとする
見ようとする場合は コンタクトを取らなくちゃ見えないんですね
いわゆる目と対象がぶつからなくちゃ見えない
情報が入りませんだから
伝達しないんだから そこで対象が目にぶつかろうとしたんだけど
そのぶつかった瞬間で目は消えていたんだと
そうするとぶつかる相手がなかったんだから
その人には見えないんです
そこで目が現れて見ようとしたんだけど
その瞬間にその対象が消えていたんだと
そうすると目が開いたんだけど
見えないんです そこで目が現れた瞬間に
その対象も現れた瞬間にいる
それでちょうどぶつかるんですね
ぶつかったら見たと そこで私はロウソクのロウソクを立て
火をつけて ロウソクの炎を 1時間見ているんだと
普通の常識で知ってるでしょ
ロウソクの炎っていうのはずっと消えていくんだと
で 目にはどうやってそれ見えるんですかね 1
時間もロウソクの炎があったんだと
で 目も同じくロウソクの炎と同じ速さで現れて消えて現れて消えていくんですよ
でも 目がうの状態で 炎もうの状態で互いに触れる
そこで あっ あるんだと決める
また 無の状態で互いに会って
あっ あるんだと決める
無の状態でわからない
ちょっとずれたらもうわからない
例えば目があるんだけど
炎がない瞬間でもわからないし
炎があっても目がない瞬間でもわからないし
両方とも一緒にない瞬間でも
もうまるっきりわからないし
そこで目が無の状態である
対象もろうそくの炎も無の状態にいる
その時は触れて知るんです
ですから 我々の知識 全部うろんなんです
我々は本当にろうそくの炎があるとしか知らないんです
いくら頭でわかってますよ
ろうそくの炎はずっと消えていくんだから
新しいろうが出てきて
それは煙になって燃えちゃって
もう出て また次のろう
次のろう 次の 見てるとろうが上がっていることも見えるんだけど
それだったら炎も消えることも見えるはずでしょうに
いくら見ても見えませんよ
どんなからくりで見ても見えません
絶対それはありえないんです
見える瞬間捕まること
で それは見えるだけではなくて
音の場合も同じ 音も物質だから
あるないあるないという波動で音を存させているんですよ
耳もいつでも流れているんですね
ろうそくの炎のように
あるないあるない状態で
そこである時だけ互いに触れて
もう反応を起こして あ
音だと決める ですから
私たちにとっては音があります
ろうそくの炎もあります
目に見えるものもあります
そこで私もいますと という結論になるんです
それはうろんというんです
それはどうしようもないでしょう
目がある時 ろうそくの炎がある時
あ ろうそくの炎があると知るんだから
どうしようもないんですよ
人間がうろん作っているのは
どうしようもないことなんです
それはヤギが葉っぱやら紙の紙食べることと
どうしようもないんです
それはヤギだからそれ食べるんであって
人間はそれ食べないと
ヤギが行儀が悪いとか
なんか叱ったりするのは何の意味もないんです
カラスなんかはもうどんな残飯でも拾って食べるでしょうに
カラス批判するのはあまりも馬鹿馬鹿らしいでしょうね
カラスだからそういうのは食べるし
肉の塊とかはスズメは食べませんし
スズメだから 魚にいくら悪口言っても批判したっても歩いては来ません
泳ぐしかしないんですね
そういうふうな例えで考えちゃうと
その我々にとってはものはある瞬間でしか見えない
ですから 人間は頑固とうろんに止まっているんです
それはさらに妄想して
神様がいるんだ 魂があるんだ
永遠不滅の魂があるんだと
永遠不滅の仏 仏心とかなんとか
人間の心にあるんだとか
すべてうろんばっかり喋ってるんです
だから魚には泳ぐしかもうどうしようもないんです
足がついてないんだから歩けないんです
ということで 私たちの認識器官すべてが有無の波動でやってますから
対象の世界も有無の波動で言ってるんだから
有の瞬間で触れちゃってぶつかり合ってあるんだと認識する
そこで物質は有無でわかったとしても
心はどうですかと 心もものすごい強烈な速さで有無の
有の瞬間 無の瞬間 有の瞬間
無の瞬間で変化しているんです
変化しなきゃ知ることはできないんです
なぜならば ろうそくが目に触れた
心はまるっきり変化しなかったと
音が耳に触れた 心はまるっきり変化しなかったというならば
聞こえないでしょうに
見えないでしょうに だから心も強烈な速さで変化していくんです
有と無の波動で 物質だけじゃなくて
心も それはぐらいは体験できますよ
例えば 綺麗なものを見たら
すぐ心が明るくなってしまっちゃって
全く醜い汚いものを見ちゃったらすぐ暗くなっちゃうでしょうし
人があなた本当に美しいですね
お若いですねと言うと
すぐ気持ちが良くなるでしょうに
人にこのババ何やってるんですか？と何か言われちゃったら
ものすごく腹が立つでしょうに
ですから 瞬間に心が変わるということでしょ
瞬間に心が変わる ほんのわずかなことで変わらなきゃ認識できません
頑固と石のように石は変化しますけど
何も反応しませんと言ったら何もわからないということなんです
ですから 心も有と無の波動で変化しているんです
そこで目が有の状態にあって
対象がろうそくの炎が有の状態にいて
心も有の状態にいると知るんです
そうでないと知らないんです
そういうわけで 人間の知識すべて仏教ではあまり相手にしないんです
全部うろんですから で
うろんで知っている世界はこのアッティワードですから
ある極論なんですね 真実ではありません
真実の一部だけ 私はよくわかりやすくするために言うのは
例えば 1 分間ろうそくの炎を見ていた人が
本当にろうそくを見ているのは 30 秒だけですと
もっと厳密に言えば 30 秒よりも少ないんです
本当のところは有無ではなくて
仏教では有と まあもう一つステップ作って無なんですね
だからステップを 3 つに分けているんです
波ですから 波ですから
波が上に上がって上の上にピークになってまた落ちるでしょうに
ですから  3段階なんですね
だから日本語でどんな言葉で言った方がわかりませんだけど
まあ現れる瞬間 生消滅なんですね
生 現れる瞬間 住ある瞬間と滅つ
消える瞬間 生住滅 住というのは住生の住なんです
生 生まれる生と生住滅という 3段階なんです
ものは だから結構厳密に分けているんですね
だからろうそくは生住滅というスリーステップで変化しているんです
その波で そこで住の時しか見えないんです
生の時は現れるエネルギーだからまだできてない
住の瞬間でもうできていたんだから
それは見える 滅の瞬間に消えるとこだから見えないんです
ですから 生の瞬間で 滅の瞬間はエネルギーとしてほぼ同じなんですね
で ということは  60目も同じなんです
正中滅だから だから 1 分間ろうそくを見ていると
そこに 60 秒があります
60 秒の 3 で割ったら 20 秒でしょ
20 秒間小の瞬間があって
20 秒間メスの瞬間がじゃない
あ そうですね  20 秒間
そこで 20 秒間銃の状態なんですね
ですから  1 分間見ていたつもりなんですけど
実際に 20 秒しか見てないんだと
じゃあなんで 40 秒のことをまるっきりわからないんですかね
それわからないのおかしいでしょ
20 秒知って 40 秒は知らないんだから
だから 1 対 2 でしょうに
だから 3分の1は知っていて
3分の2は知ってない
知らないと 存在の ということは
我々の知識はすべて真理の 3分の1なんです
また 3分の2はあるんです
半分でもないんです そこでなんで気がつかないんですかね
気がつかないのはこういうことですね
例えば 20 秒間消えていて
それから 20 秒間現れて
20 秒間消えて そういう時間の流れがずいぶん遅くしてくれるならば見えるんです
あの たまに水漏れなんかしている時はゆっくりと見てください
で 水がゆっくりゆっくりまとめてまとめて
小さな小さな小さなしずくが出て
それどんどん大きくなって
どんどんこうやってぶら下がってぶら下げて
ポチンと落ちる 落ちたらそこにまたしずくがないんですね
それからまたゆっくりゆっくりゆっくりゆっくり大きくなって
ポチンと落ちると そういう風に極力スローモーションで起こるならば
もしかするとわかるかもしれません
でも ものは残念ながらスローモーションじゃないんです
物質の速さは光の速度とほぼ同じですから
もうちょっと早いんですけどね
初粒子になっちゃうと
だからその速さも 3つに分けて見なきゃダメだからね
そこで並んでいるでしょうに
例えば消えた瞬間 現れた瞬間
消えた瞬間 現れた瞬間
同じく並んでいるんだから
現れている瞬間だけ取っちゃったら
見えて見えなくなっちゃうんですね
ばらまいているんだから
物の物の瞬間 で 我々の人生の中でも
そうなんです なんで我々は人生は苦しみだと思わないかというと
まあ例えば 2時間苦労して料理作っても
料理作って 10 分で食べるでしょ
あの 10 分は楽しいんですね
そこで 2時間の苦しみを忘れちゃうと
子供育てるのは大変なんですけど
子供はちょっとニコニコと笑って遊んじゃうとすごい楽しいんですね
そこでそのもう楽しい瞬間で
あの苦しみを無視しちゃうんです
1年間  1年間病気で悩んでも
それで薬飲んだところで
すっとその病気が消えちゃったら
ありがたいと思っちゃうんです
だからこういうことでもう並べてくるんだから
例えばもう何やっても苦しみだけだと
子供の面倒を必死にやってますけど
全然一度も母親と笑ってくれないんだと
遊んでくれないと言ったら
その母親はその子供を捨てちゃうんです
この母の愛とか そんなものは全部嘘で
それは成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
なぜかって苦しみだけしかないんだから
で それで人生は苦しいというのは
苦しみだけ続いた人が苦しいと言うんですよ
苦しみ 苦しみあって その間にちょっと楽しみがあって
また苦しみ 苦しみあって
その間にまた楽しみがあると
そういう状態の人々は人生は幸福だと言っちゃうんですね
それも無知でしょうに
真実じゃないでしょうにと
いい仕事に出会うのは大変幸福だと思いますけど
仕事自体は給料は良ければ良いほど
仕事自体は難しいでしょうし
責任が多いでしょうに
それは全部ないことにして
給料と立場の立場だけ計算する
いい仕事ありますと いい立場があるんだと
そういうのを仏教の正しい知識だとも
正しい智慧だとも思わない
全部計算してくださいと
入っている収入だけ計算して金持ちだと思ったってもおかしいでしょうに
出ているところも計算しなきゃ
収入だけで金持ちに出費も考えなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そこでお金あるかないかで
そこで足し算が終わったところの結果でしょうし
例えば我々このスポーツとかなんとかやると
年俸 1 億 2億円とか言って
ああすごいなと思うし
私の息子も野球選手にしてやろうとか思ったりするでしょ
あれはすごい誤解であって
1億円も入りませんよ
手には 全部取られた分じゃ取られるんだから
結局手に残るのは普通のサラリーマンと同じぐらいなんです
だからそこは計算しない
あ 年俸 2億円ですかね
すごいなと思っちゃうだけ
そこで税金を取られるんだから
その人々はものすごい 10億円の家を建てようとかね
500万円の車を買うとか
2台買うとかね まあそれでいくらか税金はまあ残りますから
なんとなく豊かそうに見える
でも経済状態はみんな同じなんです
みんな必死になって もう家計簿というか
そこはもういじらないと
そういうことで 人間っていうのはそんな風にこのものすごい悪い経営士なんですね
ひどいんです 一部だけ計算して
入るところだけ計算して出ているところは計算しない
人生の場合も 楽しくなる瞬間だけ計算して
苦しい大変なところは計算しない
それは切り捨て それで間違っている計算結果が出てきます
仏教の違うところは そこできちんとした計算して欲しがっちゃうんですね
だからみんな無明だと
もう簡単に軽々く言うんです
そこでまた認識の問題に戻りますけど
我々の認識している知るという世界は
存在の 3 分の 1 になっているんです
存在の 3 分の 2 は知るすべはないんです
反応を起こさない もっと本当にアビダルマ的に仏教の我々
我々考えるように もうちょっと難しくすることもできますけど
さらにそれ計算できますよ
なぜならば 目も生住滅の滅だから
その目の相住滅と炎の相住滅はぴったし合うわけないんだ
それはずれちゃうんです
いつでも ずれる ずれるたびに 3 分の 1 のところではないんです
アビダルマではそこまで計算しちゃうんです
ずれるんだと ぴったしと目が現れると一緒にロウソクの炎が現れて
目も消える瞬間にロウソクの炎が消えると
もうほとんど知ってるように
もう 3 分の 2 はちゃんと知ってるよと言ってもいいんだけど
そうではない ずれがあるんです
それに心はものすごく速いんだから
そこら辺では問題はならないんですね
心はあれより随分 17倍速く生滅変化するんだから
まあ心のズレはあまり関係はないみたい
で そういうふうに私たちには何か見えない
何が見えないんですかというと
ものは消えることは見えない
ものはあることは見える
でもそれは真実ではありません
ものは消えることだけも真実ではありません
真実というのは ものは現れて消えるということは真実なんです
いわゆる変化するということ
即的な言葉で言えば 無常は無常なんですね
現れて消えて現れ だから変化するんでしょうに
前に現れたものと次に現れたものは違いますから
花は枯れた状態になって
この花が消える瞬間見えませんだけど
ある瞬間は見える ですから
無明というのは無常を知らないことです
定義として  そこまで喋ったのはただそれを言うためなんです
アウィッジャーというのは無常を知らないこと
だから無常っていうのはものすごい巨大な教えなんです
ただものは儚いものやって
そんな話じゃないんです
すべてが現れて消えて現れて消えていくんだ
それは見ることは不可能になっています
生命には ですから すべての生命は無常
無明ですよ アウィッジャーですよと
で 一応無明の話はもう定義は言ったところで終わりますけどね
で なぜならば この無明って何ですかと言えば
無常に気づかないこと
無常は体験できないこと
無常を体験できないんだから
人間はという間違っていることを体験している
その間違っていることを体験して
ありとあらゆる科学 哲学
宗教 文学を全部作っているんです
ですから そういう一つの仏教にとっては
別にもうそんなに大事な意味が持つわけじゃないんです
科学も文学も もう哲学も宗教も全部
有の状態で物があるという状態に基づいてできているんでしょうし
ものはないと言っちゃったら
そこで科学は成り立たないでしょうに
エネルギーはないと言っちゃったら
そこで科学でなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だからきちんとあるという状態で言ってるんです
で 我々いうのは あると言ったっても
それは波動ですから 生滅の波動ではでしょうと
それは発見するためには顕微鏡は役に立たないでしょう
顕微鏡っていうのは存在の存在しか掴まれませんだから
顕微鏡で見たっても その見るものの時の時しか見えませんだから
今の望遠鏡なんかで遠い遠い星を見ているでしょうに
見ている星はもうすでに死んでるんです
ないんです ないんですけど
目で見えるんです  不思議なことでしょうね
やっぱりその出ていた光がね
有の瞬間で目に触れるんだから
あそこ星があると我々は錯覚しますよ
本当に事実知ってるならば
星がないことを知るはずなんです
100億年  100億光年とか
何万光年とか 遠いところであるんだと
そこで計算して いろんな計算からいろんな実験して
今その星がないというふうに何となく推測するだけで
その推測自体もうろんなんですね
なんか今日の話 なんか役に立たないような
話になりましたけど 一応まあそういう大変な世界だとね
もう縁起論っていうの
ぐらいだけでも覚えておいてください
まあ一応わかりやすく仏教はあまり甘く見ない方がいいんです
科学的な知識を持ってるんだとかね
ヨーロッパの哲学はもうざんざん私は勉強してるんだとかね
言ったって 私の一言葉で
私はもうそれもうなんとか言いますから
それで私は口が荒いとか
勉強してないとか なんかいろんなひどいことを言うんですけどね
私は心の中で笑ってるだけ
勉強してないのは誰ですかと
わざと勉強していないふりをしているんです
勉強すると知ってるんだと言ったって何にもないんだから
どうせくだらないことだからね
私もガキ頃はできるだけのことは勉強しましたからね
かなり猛烈な速さで本なんか読みましたからね
読んだものは一応覚えているし
小学生の時からよく勉強したものは覚えているし
ですから まあそんなことは別に面白くも何でもないんです
私には カントはこう言ったとか
もうあの人はこう言ったとかね
だから何ですか カントも無常のことを言ったんだと
だから だから何ですかね
カントが言ったんだから
お釈迦様の無常はありがたいんです
それは腹が立ちますよ
そんなこと言うと カント誰ですか？と
彼も人のいろんな考え方
いろいろ交差して考えて情報を集めて言ってることだから
単なるうろんではないかと
お釈迦様が言ったことと似ていることは
どこかのバカが言ったならば
素晴らしい アメリカの何とか博士の何とかさんがやっぱり同じこと言ってるんだから
私はやっぱりすごいと思いますよと
全然もう面白くも何でもないんですよ
どこかのバカが言わない限り
仏教のことに興味ないということでしょうに
それだったらもうもともと自分の手の下に仏教という教えがあるんだからね
それを見てみればいいのに
まあそういう機会はね
日本ではもうなかったかもしれませんだけどね
私たちのは子供の時からそういう機会があったんだからね
そんなにもう人間のうろんっていうのはね
そんなにもう大変なことだとは思ってないし
なぜ勉強するかというと
普通の方々はそういう言葉借りない限り理解しないからなんですよ
今の人々はどんな言語を使っているかという
単なる言語論なんですよ
私にとって科学の知識っていうのは単なる言語論なんですよ
ですから その単語を探してるんです
それを教えやらああだこうだとか
波動とか そういう全部もう単なるもう単語ですよ
まあとにかくあの その存在の生老病死の波動を理解できない
理解できないというのは
皆様方悪いんだからじゃないんです
頭が悪いんだからでもないんです
そういう問題じゃないんです
ただ それは不可能 それだけ
目を持っている限りはもう見るものは決まっているでしょうに
例えば我々の目には紫外線は見えません
あなたに紫外線見えません
あなた本当に盲ですね
言う人がいないでしょうに
蝶々には紫外線も見えるだそうです
それは蝶々だから見えるんであって
人間にはもうこれはまるっきり不可能
猫科の動物には色の区別はそれほどない
猫にいくら色の色彩を教えたっても
それは無理でしょうし
だから自分飼ってる猫がバカですよと言うのは良くないでしょ
猫だから色色をきめ細かい色は見えない
そういうふうなことで
我々生命にとっては 認識する機能
生命っていうのは単なる認識する機能である
このものにとっては ものは有の状態でしか
こちらで新しいエネルギーを作ることはできないんです
で 他の手でたとえで言えば
例えば手と手をぶつかって
この音を 拍手の音を出すんですね
で 拍手の音を出すためには
左手があって右手があってぶつからなくちゃいけないでしょうに
もしぶつからない こうやってぶつからなかったならば
音がないでしょう だからそこに新しい認識というエネルギーは生まれなくちゃいけないんです
それにはぶつかる必要あるんです
認識もエネルギーなんです
心も ですから あるものはある時
ある目に目がある瞬間でぶつかったところで新しいエネルギーが生まれる
で その新しいエネルギーは心が認識する
それは認識のからくり
システムなんですね そういうことで
アヴィッジャーというのは無明
無常 知らないことをアヴィッジャーというんです
それ同時に 知るためには特別な方法をしなくちゃいけないんですね
それで仏教では方法論できてあって
それで仏教に宗教というんです
単なる哲学だけではなくて
観念的な教えではなくて
それは実際に事実を体験して
それによって幸福になって
その方法論を教えているんですね
ですから 哲学と違って仏教は宗教になっているんです
で 宗教だからといって
うろの宗教とはまるっきり変わりますけどね
うろんばっかり喋ってて
神様とかなんとかとか
魂とかアーマンとかいう拝みなさいとかね
お祈りしなさいとかね
そういうふうな この人
あるシステムに束縛される宗教
まあそれ それは宗教の中の差ですからね
それでこの無常を見る方法がありますと
その工夫なんですよ もうとことんスローモーションにしてくださいと言ってるでしょ
ヴィパッサナーでも スローモーションにしてみてください
何でも焦らないで 体に心にとことん余裕を与えてくださいと
手を挙げる場合は それはわかってます
もう手を挙げると そうじゃなくて
1 分間  2 分間  5 分間でも時間心に上げてみてくださいと
手を挙げることを観察するために
5 分間かけてでもゆっくりゆっくり手を挙げてみるならば集中して
これは発見できます 心に余裕さえあれば
それだけやらないんだから
もうわかってる ただ それだけでもしっかりやるともう見えるはずなんです
妄想がなし 何も心 他のところに持っていかない
ただ手だけゆっくりと上げることを
普通だったらもう 0.5 秒で上げる手を 5 分間かけて上げてみると
上げてみる ずっと手の動きを感じて
感じて感じてみると そこで頭にものすごいすごい違う世界が見えてきます
そこで智慧の世界がそういうことでも現れるはずなんです
ですから これまあ見ることでしかね
認識することで同じ方法でしかできませんし
それからもう一つ アヴィッジャーの定義がございます
アヴィッジャーっていうのはドッカであることを知らないこと
すべては苦であると 苦しみであると知らないと
で すべては苦しみであるということを
同じくすべては無常であるという意味なんですね
いわゆるもう何の意味もない
ドッカといえば何となく感覚的でしょ
ですから 無常といえば
日本語の無常は感覚的なんですけど
無常 インパーマネンスという英語の言葉でなんと哲学的なんですね
で 苦しみといったらやっぱり主観的で
なんとなく感覚的なんですね
ですから そこら辺はもっと味が深いし
意味は同じ で いわゆる何でも変化しているんだから
もう何の価値もないし
どちらに価値があるかで
どちらにも価値がないし
価値があるわけでもないわけでもどっちでもないし
ただ変化していくだけで
それ捕まろうとするんだから
もう大変なひどい目に遭うし
ですから一切は 存在は
生きることは苦しみであるとわからない
それにアヴィッジャーという無明というんです
それから苦しみであることはわからないんだから
幸福になりたいと人間は思っているんです
この人間 幸福になりたいと思っているのはものすごい勘違いで
思えば思うほど不幸になっちゃうんです
で どういうことかというと
で 人間が幸福になろうと思って不幸を招くんですよ
例えばお金が消えました
ああ 苦しいんだ 不幸だと
私は幸福になりたいというで
その場合は その場合 私は聞きます
あなたは不幸だ 苦しみだとおっしゃいます
なぜでしょうかと 私の貯金は全部人に騙されて取られたんだと
結婚の約束してお金を持って行ったんだけど
その人は逃げちゃったんだと
ですから苦しいんだと
ですから私は幸福になりたいと
あなたはどのようにすれば幸福になりますかと聞いたところで
お金があれば幸福ですよと言うんですよ
ですから その場合は その人はお金があれば幸福だ
ある人が結婚相手がいれば幸福だ
ある人は仕事はスムーズにいけば幸福だと
ある人は収入が増えれば幸福だと
ある人は健康であるならば幸福だと
ある人は子供さえ元気で一人前の人になってくれれば
まあそれで私には十分だ
幸福だと思っちゃう そこで人間の幸福論はまちまちなんです
見てください すべて苦しみそのものでしょうに
全部それから苦しみが生まれたんだから
お金から苦しみが生まれたならば
またお金あったらまた同じ苦しみでしょうに
結婚してひどい目に遭った人が離婚して
それから再婚する なんで再婚するんだと
やっぱり人生は楽しめなくちゃと
一回その同じ楽しめなくちゃと思って結婚して
大変苦しみを味わって離婚しちゃったんだから
また同じことの繰り返しでしょうに
ですから 人間が幸福になりたいというこの気持ちさえ
とてつもない勘違いで
それによって延々と苦しみが続く
ですから 仏教で人間が幸福になりたいというこの気持ちに違う言葉を使っているんです
渇愛という言葉 タンハーという言葉
タンハー 日本語で渇愛
渇いて喉が渇いたという感じ
愛は愛ですね いわゆるわかりやすい言葉では欲なんですね
何に欲をしているんだと聞くと
この生住滅のものの住の状態があってほしいと
住の状態だけないんだから
そちらに だから花が綺麗だと思って花が取っちゃっても花が枯れていっちゃうんだから
子供は可愛いんだけど
子供そこじゃ子供大きくなって大人になって
もう抜かりしなくて出て行っちゃいますから
ですから全部変化するんですよ
だからこれというものを得て幸福というものはあるはずがない
決してないんです 例えば宝くじでも当たったとする
そうすると あ それだったらもう幸福だ
とんでもないんです 当たった途端もう新しい苦しみがそこに待ってるんです
ですから 人間の幸福になりたいという考え方自体
もうとてつもない勘違いなんです
それに仏教でいうのはただの欲ですよと
で 他のわかりやすい言葉でこう言うんですよ
病気になりたくない人が
病気になりたくないために
病気になるものばっかり探し求めているんだと
死にたくない人々は 死にたくないために死ぬものばっかり探し求めているんだと
それは愚か者の探求であると
聖者の探求は違うんだと
そういうお釈迦様の随分古いお経に
そういう聖者の探求というタイトルのお経がありまして
そこでそう書いているんです
ですから 人間の幸福論というのは
もうそれ自体 仏教では全くもう相手にしないんです
単なる勘違いだけですよ
で それにだからもう 2番目なんですね
すべては生きることは苦しみであると
もうわかってない その上
人間に幸福論というとんでもないことがあるんです
渇愛があるんですね 苦しみが渇愛から生まれるんだと
欲から生まれるんだと
あるいは我々の現代日本語で言うならば
幸福になりたいんだから不幸になるんだと
それわかってない そこで 3番目のステージでは
この幸福になりたいとかね
あるいはあの この欲ですか
欲なんか捨てちゃったら
まあどうせ無常だから
すべて変化するんだから
ある瞬間だけ気に入ったんだけど
だからってそのセット全部もらったら大変苦しみなんですね
いい例が思い浮かんだ
虎がいるんでしょ 虎が
虎っていうのは結構かわいいでしょ
見るとすごい もう体綺麗で
もう毛がすごい綺麗な
猫よりはすっごいかっこいいんです
でもそのかっこいいのは絵で見るときと
檻の中で見るときだけなんです
だから虎がすごく可愛くてかっこいいんだからって家に連れて行く
家に連れてどうなるんですかね
危なくてもう大変なんですよ
ですから このもののほんのわずかな瞬間は綺麗ですよ
それはもうその通りなんです
どんな現象にも ある瞬間は綺麗で
心がいいなと思ってしまいます
だからそのセットそのまま持っていこうとする
ご飯の場合でも 食べる瞬間は綺麗
もういいんだけど ご飯の材料とか片す
もう支度とか もうこれはただ苦しいだけなんですよ
時間を計りながら もう硬さ計算しながら
もういろいろ切り方があるわ
もういろんなシステムあるんだから
それすごい神経もかかっちゃうし
1時間煮込まなくちゃいけないものがあって
もうもう五分六分に煮なくちゃいけないものがあって
この前テレビで見たんだけど
スパゲティの煮方とか何とかとか
それはわずか と まあ二
三秒時間変えたところで味が変わるんだとか
よくバカなことをやってますけどね
それで聞いている皆様方も
やっぱりプロ並みの美しい美味しいスパゲッティ作ろうと思って
また時計合わせ時計狂っちゃったら全部狂っちゃいますけど
で 作ろうとするでしょうし
その時でも考えてみてください
料理後 美味しいご飯そこで食べる場合
食べる瞬間は本当に楽しいんですが
食べる前の時も時間長いのに
食べるとこは 10 分 作る時は 1 時間ですから
それから片付けにはまた 1 時間でしょ
だから でも我々はバカもんだから
全部セットで幸福だと思っちゃうんです
だから瞬間だけ楽しいんだから
このセット丸ごとにとっちゃったら
虎をうちに持っていったことと同じなんですよ
それから大変なんでワニも飼ってる人々いるんだけど
ワニも結構もう可愛いことは可愛いんだけど
だから顔を見るだけは可愛いんだけどね
で 他のことめんどくさいでしょうに
苦しみでしょうに 犬猫を飼ったっても同じことですよ
遊んでくれる瞬間だけはもう楽しいんだけど
餌をあげなくちゃいけない
散歩してあげなくちゃいけない
お風呂に入れてあげなくちゃ
ものすごい仕事あるし
そういうのはストレスになるでしょうし
あ 今日は犬の散歩もできなかったとかね
あ どうしようかとか そこで病気になったら我々の保険があるんだけど
ペットにはそれもないし
だからお医者さんは取りたい放題ですから
人間手術すると もっとそこでいろいろどうすればお金が安くなるかともういろいろ考えちゃいますけど
保険に折れるようにいろいろ考えたりとかね
犬の場合はもう猫の場合はまるっきり何一つもない
ですから やっぱり人間っていうのはもうセットで全部取ろうとする
だから無常から見れば
この瞬間だけ苦しみだから
取るべきセットは一つも見つからないんですね
ですから 何も取らないことは
何にも執着しないことは幸せで幸福であるということを人間はわからないんです
いわゆる執着を捨てること
割りを捨てることこそ
この無常の流れの中で瞬間美味しいんだから
すべて取ろうとしたらひどい目に遭うということはわからない
だから何も取らない方が正しいんだと
それは理解しない それにも無明というんです
で  4番目に 人間というのは
この無常を見る方法を知らない
いわゆるこの生老病死の波動の中で
銃だけ見ているんだけど
この生の瞬間と滅の瞬間
あるいはものの消える瞬間
自分が消える瞬間 それを見た方が
やっぱりもうものは全部変化しているんだ
だからここに私もあるわけでもないし
他にもあるわけじゃなくて
単なる現象の流れだけですよと
そこに自我がないということで
執着は消えちゃって解脱するんですよ
その方法を知らない だからその方法に仏教では中道とも言うし
八正道とも言うんです
この生老滅のシステムを知る方法に
で その方法は誰一人も知りません
知る術もないんでしょうね
なぜならば すべてあるあるという知識しかないんだから
あることのカラクリをやっているだけでないということは
ないということは あることは全く全く知りませんだから
ないという側面もあるんだと知りませんだから
ですから 人間の知恵では
知識では 頭では決して八正道は発見できません
それで仏教の初期仏教の乗左仏教の両方のも
典型的なアヴィッジャの定義は
ドッカを知らないこと
ドッカの苦を知らないこと
苦集知らない 苦の集知らないこと
苦の滅 苦しみを消えることを知らないことと
道道知らないこと いわゆる苦集滅道という四聖諦
知らないことはアヴィッジャというというんです
それ全く全くその通りで
で そこで話は一応終了させますけど
で そこでちょっとした注意があるんです
例えば皆様方は経典とか
なんとか原始経典とか
なんとか誰かの先生方が書いた本なんかを見ると
先生っていうのは経典にあるものはなんと書き写すだけなんですね
そこで無明 無明はなんでしょうかと経典にちゃんと定義しているんです
無明はドッカを知らない
ドッカのサムデを知らない
いわゆる空を知らない
住を知らない 滅を知らない
道を知らない それはアヴィッジャといいます
それしか見つからないんです
あ なんだ それぐらいの教えかと
なんか仏教を軽く見落としているんです
ですから それぐらいの教えじゃないんです
その中に大変な考え方があって
そういう定義をしているんです
ですから 確かに空住滅道を知らないことは無明なんです
でも学者みたいに知識だけを持って経典を読んでも
その深い真理には決して出会わない
本読んでもうろんにしか何もないんだから
だから釈迦の教えなんかはそれほど高度な教えじゃないかと思う人々もいるみたいですけどね
それはその方々は高度でないことであって
釈迦の高度の教えを教えてないわけじゃないんです
その弟子たちに教えた
あの 舎門浄とかなんとか
そんなことではないんです
それは真理そのものなんです
ですから いつでもどこかで我々の落とし穴があるんですよ
単なる経典 文字だけ読んでしまうと
まあ同義語やらいろんな専門用語が並んでいるだけで
その深い深くある隠れている
その真理はただ読むだけで
理解することだけでは発見できない
まあ一応まあ それは無明の話なんです
で いろいろ質問ございましたらもう聞いてください
ありがとうございます